[Music]
on this Monday night Hawaii's need for
essential supplies volunteers working
relentlessly to provide relief you're so
devastating plus the challenges
firefighters faced and the potential
class action lawsuit against the power
company
residents in the Northwest Territories
on the run from raging wildfires while
BC braces for a heat wave the help for
the most vulnerable
Afghanistan's plummeting economy
sometimes I wonder if I should sell one
of my kidneys to help support my family
the debilitating Ripple effects of the
taliban's restrictions on women working
global national with Donna Friesen
reporting tonight para Nasser good
evening to you thank you for joining us
Hawaii's deadly wildfires will be
heavily studied as our planet heats up
that's according to climate experts a
weekend the damage is estimated to be
more than 7 billion dollars but of
course the loss of life is the most
devastating 96 people have died and for
those who survived the harrowing ordeal
will stay with them forever yet there
are also incredible stories of strangers
helping others
this wall here is the only thing that
was keeping us from burning the VA
family was stuck in traffic trying to
flee as the fire moved closer they
started to run when a grandmother in
another car cried out for help
and she's just telling me please help me
I have a baby I reached over I grabbed
this baby
she was about two and a half three years
old
I grabbed her she had she was sitting on
a blanket I wrapped her with a blanket
and I told my kids you guys run
other families were not as lucky with
hundreds still missing as Crews sift
through the ashes officials are bracing
for the number of dead to increase
we are prepared for
many tragic stories they will find 10 to
20 people per day probably until they
finish
and it's probably going to take 10 days
it's impossible to guess really
many Maui residents have banded together
to help however they can and that's on
top of the aid coming in from the
military and the U.S federal emergency
management agency cell service
throughout the island is now slowly
being restored but it is just the start
of what will be a very long road to
recovery our Anita Garcia is in Maui and
she joins us just off the shore of
Lahaina what can you tell us about the
situation there and the volunteer Aid
efforts
far access to Lahaina byground has been
largely limited to Emergency Operations
and residents even some Vehicles filled
with donated food and supplies are being
restricted we're hearing one of the main
needs is prescription medication and
water so volunteers like this group
behind me are finding other ways to get
those where they're needed
a human chain of volunteers loading up
private boats with specific supplies
requested by locals in Lahaina we are
working 17 hours a day just to get this
up and going taking our own private
boats directly over to our contacts we
have seen the devastation which
is absolutely heartbreaking friend's
wife was remains was found in the house
so that's uh he's pretty sad too so
volunteer chemo Burley says everyone
living on the island is impacted and
they're finding ways to get Aid where
it's needed we much rather be driving
this over there but if we're not
permitted to take that Highway into
Lahaina
and this is the only other option other
than Maybe by plane or helicopter
got medicine those who were still in the
decimated Community have severely
limited power cell service and clean
water this group is trying to get them
what they need
devastating a lot of my family members
have lost their homes
also who had them die in the fire that's
all we need here in line is prayers and
any kind of monetary everybody lost
their jobs we love you all God bless I
can't do anything else like I can't not
be here first time we came up here I was
in tears
thinking like
it looks like a war zone our drone
captured this footage of Lahaina on
Sunday with buildings vehicles and
houses leveled it's home to heartbreak
as questions are mounting over the cause
of the blaze which is still under
investigation FBI evidence recovery
teams are now on scene there are reports
as the fire tore through here lahaina's
water system collapsed and fire hydrants
were running dry Hawaiian Electric is
facing a class-action lawsuit alleging
this could have been avoided if power
had been shut down before hurricane
strength winds hit the area 12 to 18
trips every single day but for Carl
Snyder and his group even with the
National Guard and Federal Emergency
Management Agency on the ground they
don't plan to ease their own relief
efforts anytime soon we brought baby
formula this woman ran up and hugged one
of our colleagues
it crying thank you because my baby I
didn't have any food
um that made all the difference
as volunteers drop off gas food and
water to the shores people in Lahaina
are being offered free shuttles to
stores in Central Maui part of a service
which launched on Sunday the situation
in Lahaina is desperate but one
sentiment we've heard over and over
again is that through their heartbreak
people are finding hope and the tireless
efforts of volunteers trying to help how
they can is one example of that pharah
Nathan Garcia off the island of Maui
thank you for your coverage nitu
in this country another fire emergency
members of the Canadian Forces have been
deployed to deal with wildfires raging
in the Northwest Territories near the
Alberta border more than 230 fires are
burning the ones posing the biggest risk
are near Hay River triggering evacuation
orders for thousands of people some
evacuees have been airlifted South to
safety that includes two flights from
Fort Smith to Fort McMurray that carried
more than 110 evacuees and more are
expected to arrive from Hay River by air
and by boat as Heather York's West
reports for those forced to flee it's
been a nerve-wracking few days
just 12 at six o'clock and you can see
the darkness from from the smoke in the
South slave region of the Northwest
Territories residents had little time to
pack up and go they barely made that
through they were driving through Flames
as the fire approached the only Highway
out of Hay River Ashley gressel
facetimed her family as they made their
harrowing Escape you can just hear
everybody really panicked and my mom was
trying to coordinate my dad through
literal Flames like there's flames on
both sides they ended up in the ditch
once and they got out and there was a
semi truck completely engulfed in flames
that they had to get around it was a
quickly advancing fire from Alberta that
forced residents of Fort Smith and Hay
River to flee then we have ss052 which
is moving East that one's moved through
Enterprise towards Hay River and Fort
Smith South of Hay River fire swept
through the Hamlet of enterprise
we currently have our cruise during
Summit assessment of the area to figure
out exactly the extent of the burning
and the structure loss at this time we
don't know updates are slow because
across the region the fire has
compromised communication lines as well
I think people are very scared people
are trying to get a hold of their
relatives and they can't by Monday
anyone left in Hay River was told to
head to the airport the highway now
completely closed a Hercules actually
flew in from Fort Smith this morning I
didn't know until early this morning
that it was a Hercules
so they were thankfully able to get a
large group out a number of flights from
Fort Smith or Hay River brought evacuees
to Fort McMurray throughout the day
military help is expected to arrive in
the region Tuesday officials say it is
not safe for anyone to stay Heather
urich's West Global News
a heat wave is settling over much of
British Columbia and it's expected to
last until at least Thursday areas of
coastal BC couldn't see temperatures hit
the mid 30s while areas further Inland
could hit nearly 40 degrees more than
600 people died during the unprecedented
heat dome in 2021 in BC and health
authorities are urging people to take
this heat warning seriously Global's
Grace key is in Vancouver Grace what's
being done to help vulnerable people in
this weather
pharah I'm in the city's West End a lot
of the apartments here are older with no
air conditioning this neighborhood also
has one of the highest concentrations of
people in the region a lot of them are
seniors the 600 people who died during
the heat Dome a majority of them were
seniors and many of them died indoors
Joe pack is in here to keep things
cool so for the second year in a row the
city of Vancouver and the local health
authority have teamed up with Community
groups to hand out cool kits now there's
a spray and water bottle gel compress
towel and a small container you can fill
with water and a thermometer to check
indoor temperatures temperatures above
26 degrees may be unsafe for vulnerable
people and anything above 31 should be
avoided for those at a greater risk of
heat illness and we can certainly all do
our part check on your neighbors and
Elders the best thing we can do is
support seniors to help other seniors so
we've trained seniors in our community
to have the knowledge and resources to
do heat checks with their own colleagues
and friends so they look after each
other and along the way they build up
their own knowledge of what to look for
it's certainly not expected to heat up
like we saw during the heat dome but
many agencies are taking the lessons we
learned from a couple of years ago and
trying to be proactive now pharah Grace
Kate and Vancouver thank you Grace
a judge in Montana has ruled in favor of
a group of young climate activists who
argue state agencies were violating
their constitutional right to a clean
environment the judge found the state
was violating the rights of young people
with policies that permitted fossil fuel
development without considering the
impact on the climate the ruling is the
latest in a small number of decisions
around the world that affirm a
government's duty to protect its
citizens from climate change
to the political turmoil in the U.S now
former U.S president Donald Trump is on
the verge of being indicted in a fourth
criminal case this one involving his
attempts to overturn the 2020 election
results in the state of Georgia the
grand jury began hearing the case today
and could decide on charges as early as
tomorrow as Jackson prosco reports the
potential charges are sprawling
under tight security and Atlanta grand
jury faces a heavy task weighing charges
against a former president for alleged
election subversion more than two years
of Investigation by district attorney
fonnie Willis have led to this point
funny Wallace understands that this was
not a couple of one-off criminal
acts that she wants to prosecute but
rather a full-fledged fully developed
conspiracy to overthrow the election
more than a dozen Trump allies also risk
being indicted as prosecutors linked
together multiple threads from the
aftermath of the 2020 election from the
Trump supporters caught accessing voting
machines to Republicans who falsely
signed paperwork claiming Trump won
Georgia and then there are Trump's own
letters and phone calls pressuring State
officials to overturn the rightful
outcome of the vote I just want to find
780 votes which is one more that we have
have because we won the state a perfect
phone call according to Trump but
prosecutors see a likely conspiracy they
seem set to bring racketeering charges
and charges of making false statements
among other felonies Biden's newest
Lackey Atlanta D.A Bonnie Willis Trump
is already lashing out running
commercials attacking the D.A so
dishonest on social media he's going
after prosecutors and Witnesses in a
risky legal strategy that may be the
quickest way for the former president to
be wearing an orange jumpsuit so he
needs to be really careful you don't
want to be seen as intimidating
Witnesses or trying to intimidate
prosecutors
that does not seem likely to dissuade
the former president who has long
claimed he is in fact the victim if
convicted of state level charges in
Georgia he would not be eligible for a
presidential pardon Jackson prosco
Global News Washington
a supermarket in Odessa has been
destroyed following a Russian missile
attack he created an authority say eight
missiles and 15 drones were intercepted
by its air defense systems but Falling
debris sparked Fires at several
buildings causing extensive damage at
least three people were injured ports in
the Odessa region have come under heavy
Fire by Russia since the collapse of the
black seat grain deal last month
tragedy strikes a quiet neighborhood
coming up the deadly blast that
obliterated three homes
Europe's most active volcano is added
again as Mount Aetna puts on a
mesmerizing display it's located in the
Italian island of Sicily and rarely
causes significant damage although the
eruption's volcanic ash is forcing the
temporary closure of Sicily's Catania
airport Mount Aetna is believed to have
the longest documented history of
eruptions among all volcanoes with
records dating back as early as 425 BC
at least five people were killed in a
Pennsylvania house explosion that was
caught on camera and a warning some of
these images might be disturbing
about the windows and doors and about a
dozen neighboring houses as well three
residents were injured and nearly 60
firefighters were treated for medical
issues when Flames rapidly spread the
cause of the explosion is still under
investigation
[Music]
plunged into poverty ahead how the
taliban's Takeover of Afghanistan is
crippling the country's economy
at least 36 people are feared dead and
Myanmar after being swept into a lake by
a landslide and a jade mine eight others
were injured and taken to hospital it
happened in picant an area known for the
world's most lucrative Jade mines mining
operations had been suspended because of
the rainy season however many of those
missing are believed to be locals who
were digging through the mud looking for
precious stones
Afghans around the world are preparing
to Mark a grim anniversary tomorrow
marks two years since the Taliban seized
control of Kabul the country's economy
has been pushed to the brink of collapse
in that time the U.N says the number of
Afghans living in poverty has nearly
doubled soaring to 34 million people in
part two of our series on the plight of
Afghans to goofadanish looks at the
struggle to survive under Taliban rule
in downtown Kabul Ahmad masood's grocery
store shelves are fully stocked but
these days he says customers are in
short supply
a lot of stores aren't doing so well
that one used to be a tailor shop and it
had to close because it wasn't getting
any business all across Afghanistan
families are struggling to survive in a
country of just over 40 million people
their world food program says 92 percent
of people in the country do not have
enough to eat and 6 million are just one
step away from famine
two years after the Taliban is turned to
power Afghanistan's economy remains
shattered nine hundred thousand Afghans
have lost their jobs according to the
international labor organization and
women like zainabrazoi have borne the
brand of taliban's crippling restriction
Reza used to be her family's breadwinner
she worked two jobs to support her
widowed mother and siblings until the
Taliban made it illegal for her to work
those jobs
I have nothing left to sell sometimes I
wonder if I should sell one of my
kidneys to help support my family
experts say that talibans cracked down
is putting women's lives at rest women
are dying right now because of lack of
access to health care because of of
barriers the Taliban put in the way so
far the taliban's efforts to get
Afghanistan's economy back on track have
felt businesses aren't investing
construction has grown to a halt and
hundreds of thousands of Afghans are out
of work even the Taliban admits the
situation is dire
because of the international
restrictions placed on our government we
have no access to our assets so our
economy will continue to struggle
countries around the world in including
have refused to recognize the Taliban
making it harder to deliver humanitarian
Aid the ndp's Foreign Affairs character
says Canada needs to do more we need
people to get dollars into the talent
into the into Afghanistan to make sure
that those people are are are able to
eat are able to survive and and we have
to do that despite the Taliban until the
Taliban comes up with a plan for the
country's economy there is little hope
this situation will improve
a bleak outlook for Afghans already
struggling to survive sugar fadonesh
Global News Ottawa
tomorrow looks at the taliban's
systematic question of Rights especially
for women and girls and what it's like
to be banned from participating in
public life in Afghanistan tonight's
your Canada is this hot air balloon over
the Old Man River in Lethbridge Alberta
and we love senior Canada so please keep
emailing us your photos to viewers at
globalnational.com
until tomorrow take care of yourselves
and each other good night
[Music]
thank you